so now we know what a function is we
know what a function isn't a much easier
way than to try and deal with this with
with numbers and with like trying to do
tables in our head is just to draw
things so I would like you to draw
whoopsie-daisy I'd like you to draw one
set of axes so that's four for each of
these and we're going to draw a picture
and find a much easier way like rather
than all this fancy language really
simple visual way to work out is
something a function or is it not so can
you draw those four sets of axes for me
they don't even need to be too large I
usually like quite large diagrams but
these can be quite small draw four sets
of axes and let's real quick draw each
of these roughly and see what's going on
so on my first of our set of axes I'm
gonna draw this guy y equals 2x minus 3
what kind of a shape will I draw what
category is shaping my drawing this is a
straight line very good what can you
tell me about the straight line from
these numbers let's say the two without
tell you it's going to be going from
left to right it's going up is it is it
shallow or is it steep good to two this
is the gradient right so gradients rise
over run so every time you go across one
unit you go up two that's what that
gradient means this is quite steep yeah
what about the negative three what does
that tell us
anyone oh it's the y-intercept so this
tells me where I am
up and down okay so very very roughly
speaking it's gonna look something like
that
let's make that negative three let's
just call that y equals two X minus
three okay to get the pattern I'm gonna
draw all of these or four of these and
then we'll work out what is it that
clearly distinguishes the functions from
they're not functions okay
y equals x squared this is really easy
to draw where we've really good this
what kind of shape is it look carefully
it's a parabola right so you know this
shape it's gonna look like this
how's that
it passes through the origin if that's
where its vertex is so it's kind of like
was extra sweat okay
now this guy here you've not drawn this
before hmm it's like the graph we just
did it is actually a parabola but I've
swapped my X's and Y's right now
excellent Y's are the horizontal and
vertical axes yeah
horizontal vertical so if I got this by
swapping horizontal and vertical here
instead of being like concave up and
down see how this parabolas up and down
this is gonna go sideways right so I
will save you a bit of work I want you
to look at this graph here and then I
want you to turn your head 90 degrees to
the left can you do that for me left
what you're looking at is see this is
the x-axis right now but it's going to
become your new Y axis and this is your
y-axis right now boom it's gonna become
your new x axis so everything's gonna be
sideways this is what it looks like okay
it's still a parabola but instead of
going up and down it goes left and right
okay it still passes through okay last
one what was this shape again it's a
circle what can you tell me about this
circle where's its center it's at the
origin and what's its radius one so this
in fact is not just any circle this is
the unit circle so let's draw this
okay so on the top here at least the way
I've drawn I don't know how you've
arranged your page these guys I've said
we're functions
I need my green this is a function this
is a function okay
but this is not a function and neither
is this okay sir
what visually tells you something's a
function or not I mean what's your
suggestion functions don't only work on
graphs but for the sake of simplicity to
start off an idea just like a great
parallel to your question is
trigonometry does trigonometry only work
in right-angled triangles and the answer
is we now know you can use it in any
triangle you like right but when we
first met it we didn't explore that
world because it would have made your
brains explode okay so we're gonna start
with just graphs and later on you'll
learn about other things okay all right
and yeah your handout what was your
suggestion okay so because Aaron's
suggestion it has to do with the X's and
Y's so what we're saying is each input
which is an X X has exactly one output
which is why like this okay so if you've
got a ruler or even your pen will do
just anything that's straight okay what
I want you to do is take it and put it
on your page so that it's vertical okay
now watch what happens as I look through
each graph okay this graph here as I put
this across I'm imagining this is like
an x value so if I put this here it's
like x equals zero if I moved that over
here it's like x equals negative one x
equals one x equals two so I can move
this left and right as I move my ruler
from left to right do you see I only
ever hit the graph once do you see that
look for example here there's the spot I
hear as I move there's the spot I hear
here now here does that make sense so I
take a vertical line and I use it as my
test it works all the way across what
about the parabola as I move from left
to right I'm only ever touching the
graph once can you see the point of
intersection can you sort of imagine it
as it moves okay now have a look at this
parabola have a look at this parabola
when I put the line here just right
there it is fine isn't it like you see
that that's got exactly one output it
hits just once at the origin but the
second I move it a little bit like this
now we're in trouble it hits twice once
twice so this single output gets sorry
single input gets two outputs and it
keeps on getting to all the way does
that make sense and the same thing is
here right there are there's a couple of
perfect spots do you see them there's a
couple of spots where you get one input
where are they on the edges right look
there's exactly one and there's exactly
one but most of the time you get two
right I don't have just one output I've
got multiple outputs in fact later on
I'll show you graphs where you can have
three or four or infinite outputs and
they are definitely definitely not
functions okay